[Music]
[Applause]
now
the pride of bowling green is scottie
miller the
tampa bay buccaneers wide receiver joins
us on the program
scotty thanks for joining us uh
congratulations getting to the super
bowl
thank you thanks for having me on all
right take me into the huddle
final play first half what's the play
call
yeah so i mean even before that just to
go for it
um that was a big decision for the
coaches on that on that fourth down but
then for that play call we we just
called
a go route for me and mike i really
thought i was going to turn into hail
mary type of thing
i was telling chris before the play to
widen out with me in the bunch
um but then that came on just single
high defense so i was able to get a
one-on-one match up and
uh he wasn't even bailing too too fast
like i'm sure you've seen so i was able
to just get right by him
but when did you know that this could
turn into a touchdown
yeah so like before the play like i said
i wasn't really expecting this to happen
at all but right when i right when i
took off and i saw him not running
in my head i'm like dude i'm like number
20. you better start running it
so at that moment when i saw him just
kind of like in a slow backward i'm like
i'm about to score and then i looked up
at some times it's not the same thing i
did the ball just floating
but how do you hide or disguise that
you're going to go deep like that i
think that they thought you guys were
going to try to get into field goal
range but
how do you hide the fact that hey i'm
going to try to blow right by you
yeah i mean for me i think first of all
the coaches did a good job i was in a
cut split
um and a bunch so they probably thought
i was gonna go running outright or
something like that
but uh for me like as far as my
technique could just run right at his
blind spot where he can't see me because
his eyes are looking at the quarterback
um so he can he doesn't know if i'm
gonna break out you know it kind of
confuses him when i run right at his
blind spot
and then i just at that point stick my
foot on the ground go by
what did brady say after the touchdown
uh
honestly i don't even know if i remember
i was going crazy i was like running
circles in the ends on you know what was
going on
um but this is an unbelievable moment he
was pumped he came
he's always celebrating with us in the
end zone he's big on that um
so you know something like let's go you
know
did you keep the football yeah i got it
absolutely
i think get brady to autograph it that'd
be nice yeah i gotta i gotta get a
couple
a couple signatures from him after the
season because jersey football
i don't think you could get king to sign
it though the packers defensive back i
think that would be mean-spirited though
scott
um when did you know you were fast
uh ever since i was able to run really
from a young age i've always been the
fastest one in my grade and i remember
winning
uh races field day in fifth and third
fourth fifth grade stuff like that i've
always been
just naturally god-given uh just blessed
with uh less unfortunate speed
but it's one thing to run on recess in a
playground
then you get on a football field and
when did you when
like there's quickness and then there's
speed when did you realize you had
speed same type of thing for me it's
always i've been doing the same type of
thing ever since i was a little kid
if you look at highlights from when i
was in playing youth football in fifth
grade when i started
i was doing the same thing just running
by dudes and catching deep balls um
so i've really just i've really had it
my whole life um
but then i did like in in high school i
think i really once i started running
track really started develop
and know that i could run um with the
best of them but you run a 4-3-9
at your pro day is that the best you've
ever run
yeah i mean that i i would like to say
it was a little lower than that
i wish i wish i got invited to the
combine so i had like a laser timing
because at my pro dad like
20 scouts with hand times and some dudes
some dudes told me i ran the high 42
some guys told me
mid-four threes it was just like
everywhere um and then 439 came out i
don't know
where that exactly comes from but i'd
like to i wish i ran one where i could
tell people exactly what i read
but you get labeled like you you
probably got bunched in
with uh julian edelman and wes welker
even though
you're not really like them and you play
in the mac you weren't highly recruited
like how did you fall through the cracks
where you really
had a hard time just you know getting
somebody's uh eyes on you
yeah it's always been a it's a tough
road for me uh ever since high school
just getting noticed
um only had one fps offer and i think
it's just because
i'm undersized um i'm still under size
in the nfl
but uh that's always made me make me
work even harder to prove people wrong
and i love the daughters
any defensive backs say man you're a
little bit faster than i thought
yeah i mean that's whenever i get to a
team whether it be bowling green
or not with the bucks or anybody i play
against or
everyone always tell me that but you and
brady got something in common though
sixth round drop picks like
official height and weight not program
official height and weight
i'm five nine right now probably lost a
couple pounds in the season probably
170.
you sure you're five nine yes i'm five
five nine yes
okay i mean it sounds better if you're
five eight
like five eight and a half like how
how would you do a few and tyreek hill
lined up
oh i'm taking me every day of the week
um i'll take me over anybody tyrique is
unbelievable uh super quick unbelievable
talent
but if we're talking about race i mean i
got all the confidence in myself against
going up against anybody
wait you think you're the fastest guy in
the nfl yes sir
[Laughter]
what's that like though to get in the
blocks in high school
and you're running 100 meters and you
look around they're probably looking at
you like
this guy run like did you have that
feeling
absolutely yeah i think people always
slept on me um
but they're gonna find that really quick
once that gun goes off they're gonna
find out really quick who's the fastest
one
uh what's the nickname that you have uh
scooter is the big one uh especially
this year tom really uh
drove that one home um so that's what
that's what everyone's been calling we
gotta get something a little more
badass like like scoot is
i don't know how about smoke smoke yeah
like smoke
smoke but you know i was thinking maybe
you don't want a name that's flashy
where
they you draw too much attention like
you gotta fly under the radar yeah
not a bad thing yeah he's uh scotty
miller he's the uh
tampa bay buccaneers wide receiver that
flight back home
what was it like from green bay oh it
was amazing it was so much fun
the locker room after was insane i never
experienced anything like that
um of course you got gronk going crazy
the whole time
is everybody having so much fun did
gronk have his shirt off
oh yeah you already know you know we did
dancing all over the place everyone's
taking videos of them but
uh we got such a great group of guys we
had a great time
but you're i mean this is pretty amazing
you're what 23
yes sir and you're around tom brady
i mean yeah it's uh it's wild i could
never imagine
any of this stuff happening so i'm just
taking it one day at a time it just it's
just
it's uh it's a crazy experience has he
yelled at you before
yeah uh he hasn't got after me too too
bad um
but him he gets on everybody he expects
he expects greatness um
so he's gonna get it out of you what's
it like
with uh are you guys gonna be in your
home
or in uh hotel uh super bowl week
we are gonna be at home i think we're we
only show up to the hotel the night
before the game so i'll be at home
uh these next two weeks are you okay
with that yeah
absolutely um i like it it's where i'm
comfortable i got my wife here
she just get to hang out with her just
like i normally do and try to make the
moment not as big as it is and i think
that'll help though
uh you watched film already with the
chiefs yeah and we've played them
uh as you know we played them earlier so
i know a lot what they do
i know the guys that they have but we'll
really get after that
tomorrow we'll be in the building all
day and then pretty much every day
leading up to the super bowl
are you recognized in tampa um
this year's different because i don't
even go out
and that last round anyone would know
who i am um
this year probably still not but uh
but occasionally if i'm at the mall or
something uh
sometimes people you know say something
to me but
if you look at me you probably don't
think that's an nfl player so
even if you had your jersey on though
scotty
i yeah they may think i'm just uh some
fan wearing
number 10 wondering who number 10 is but
how many uh tickets do you get for the
super bowl
i still don't know the answer that
question um there's trying to figure it
out i've heard
a whole bunch of different things but
i'm hoping to get as many as i can
but what kind of request how many people
have asked for tickets
oh my goodness i mean everybody you
could you could think of
um who doesn't want to come to the super
bowl that's where it's tough uh
to figure out who but i know i hope i
get at least three so i can at least get
my parents and my wife to come and then
you know try
and get a couple other people that are
really meaningful to me in my life
will you tell your kids about gronk or
about brady
uh gronk would probably be the first one
to come to mind because all the stories
and all that well give me give me a
story like what's the one where you go
you come home and you say to your wife
this is gronk
um man i don't know if i can
point to one off the top of my head but
i mean we were playing basketball and
just watching him play basketball is
pretty funny
um it was at berkeley in the summer just
watching him go up and doug could kind
of
joke around and just the way he goes
about it is he's just hilarious
but but he's not going to be doing keg
stands or anything like that you
like you missed out on that that gronk
yeah i i don't know i mean we win this
next one i don't know
i don't know hey well congratulations
it's uh been a fun ride
and uh you know the uh
big time stuff though going on that on
that field but you get to play
are you gonna feel like it's a home game
i don't know honestly i mean we'll see
um i think it's
to definitely make it seem a lot like
not as big of a moment because we're
playing our home stadium where we always
play um on any given sunday but
um we'll see i think we're all really
excited to have a lot of our fans are
going to be there so it's going to be
fun
yeah it'll be different from lambeau but
look you played in bowling green so that
you know i mean you played in cold
weather you're from chicago
so that's nothing now you get to you
know play in tempe
this year i've been used to not
everyone's used to playing in cold
weather
with no fans there that's one thing
that was your college career right
[Laughter]
hey congrats though scotty and uh it'll
be fun watching you and good luck
thanks man i appreciate you that's uh
scottie miller smoke
smoke miller